this is Jocko podcast number 232 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening from Colonel
Graz be commanding v Manchester Regiment
dear madam your letter of the 20th of
August reached me safely your poor son
died a heroic soldiers death and all
belonging to the fifth manchester
regiment from myself downwards are proud
of having been comrades of so brave and
honourable Elad I am glad to be able to
inform you he did not suffer any great
pain he died saying he hoped if he ever
got over his wounds he would soon be
able to return to his duty I'm informed
by those who were present with him in
the blockhouse at the time that he
passed away happily and willing to meet
his God you have every reason to be
proud of his memory and may God help and
comfort you in your great sorrow I will
inquire if he has left any keepsake that
could be either sent to or kept for you
I've asked my wife to call and see you
the next time she is in Manchester
believe me yours faithfully H Crosby
colonel
and that right there is a letter of
condolence written back to a grieving
mother in England during the second Boer
War in Africa South Africa and of course
the letters paints the picture of a well
let's just say a a kind of perfect
heroic death which I guess is what any
mother would want to hear but make no
mistake about any war including the Boer
War in South Africa that this scene was
awful
so the Boer War in South Africa you know
it's it's it's a war that people
consider to be one of the first modern
wars and there's there's you know you
there's a bunch of wars you could throw
in there that that are also called that
I mean the American Civil War was in
some ways considered a modern war you
know you had some some wars that were
right around there that that weren't a
modern war they were kind of a mixing
you know there was there's one battle
that the British fought against the
modest Sudanese it was in 1898 in
September of 1898 and during this battle
you know it was British soldiers and
actually Egyptian soldiers as well
versus these these Sudanese and during
the battle
there was forty eight of the British and
Egyptians who were killed 382 wounded
and on the suit and east side there was
12,000 dead and 13,000 wounded
so so that was kind of a lopsided battle
and if you stand up against the British
and try and fight them in that manner of
hey we'll go toe-to-toe we have machine
guns or we don't have machine guns but
we have we have repeating rifles we have
a massive advantage over you and you're
going to continue to charge with us
we're gonna mow you down and that's what
happened there so what happens in the
second Boer War is an early example of
asymmetric warfare meaning you have a
small group in this case the Boers which
is a Afrikaans term that means farmers
and there's between 20 and 60 thousand
of them and they're going up against the
British Empire which at the time was a
massive powerhouse obviously they end up
with 500,000 troops so three hundred and
fifty thousand Brits 150,000 Colonials
and a hundred thousand Africans that are
fighting on on the British side the it's
the second Boer War the first one took
place in 1880 but it's a it was much
much smaller started with a farmer that
refused to pay taxes you know that seems
to be a common thread we don't like to
pay taxes and the government confiscated
his farm and his equipment and they were
gonna have an auction and then these
other farmers got together and they
attacked the auction and this is the
this is the original term the term
commando which we use well we we usually
use it to talk about an individual
person but the original term meant a
group of people that was called a
commando meant you know whatever 30 40
100 guys band together kind of like a
militia group and the way and they kind
of acted in the way we think commandos
act which means they you know they would
use mobility and speed and violence of
action surprised and said ambushes and
those kind of behaviors
and meanwhile the Brits are still in
that in that in that first Boer War the
the Brits are still wearing red uniforms
you see them saying this is a total this
is a this is a strange world this is as
you know this is during the evolution of
war and they're still firing
you know the stokke setting up in lines
and firing volleys together as a group
and on command you know ready aim fire
that type of thing and meanwhile the the
Booher commandos are hiding behind trees
and the first battle that they have
there's 120 brits dead or wounded and
there's two doers dead and five wounded
so you know this this war lasted ten
weeks the first one and like I said it
was less of a war you know light action
then eventually they kind of go into
this uneasy peace and then the second
Boer War comes along and and you know
I'm just trying to give some high-level
I'm absolutely no expert on these things
and I'm sure some of some people will
let me know some things that have gotten
wrong but the second brutal war is a
fight between it's it's these allies
these these new boo or allies there's
there's two new states that are formed
one of them is called I think it's
officially called the South African
Republic but I usually see it referred
to as Transvaal and then the other
there's another state or country called
the Orange Free State and so here's the
basis of these these are a little bit
for unit you know the shape of Africa
you at the bottom of Africa where South
Africa is today you you go inland a
little bit and what happened was the
Brits at one point they stopped slavery
like no more slavery and the Brewers
they still wanted slavery because they
were farmers and they well that was part
of their economy and well they just
thought that they deserved to have
slaves
and then on top of that when they got
told hey you can't have slaves anymore
there was no kind of deal set up for
them to be compensated to say look if
you want us to change the way we're
running this economy we need to you know
we need money you know we need money to
hire people and so they look for some
kind of compensation the Brits were like
no this is an immoral activity and we're
not having slavery anymore it's all
that's over
so the Brewers or a large portion of
Brewers which again not now these are
these are different groups of people I
want to say mainly Dutch the Brewers
were mainly Dutch settlers which is why
they speak Afrikaans which is like a
version of Dutch so they about 15,000 of
them leave and they march north and so
now they set up these two states where
slavery is still allowed and they and
and they kind of exist for a while in a
you know relatively I guess in a
relatively peaceful way at least in
terms with the British well guess what
they find in this land that they end up
settling in they find gold they find
diamonds and this starts to well now you
know you gold diamonds war that's where
it leads to the there's kind of three
phases that this war goes through in the
first one the Brits are unprepared
they're not ready for this in the second
phase the Brits bring in massive numbers
of people that supplies and they kind of
just war of attrition overpower the
Brewers and then the brewers go into
like full gorilla warfare mode
insurgency mode and then the Brits go
hardcore scorched earth we're gonna win
war of attrition
first ever concentration camps I'm
pretty sure that the term concentration
camps comes from this war because what
the British ended up doing is saying
okay we don't want to we don't wanna
harm the women and children so they took
the the boo or women and children and
put them in these camps while the camps
were a total disaster and 25 plus
thousand women and children died of
starvation and disease in those camps
and eventually just through just harsh
brutality the boomers were broken and
they surrendered in 1902 but from a
perspective from just a strategic
perspective if you think about this it
took three long bloody and expensive
years for the mighty British Empire to
defeat these kind of ad hoc commando
units from the Boomer side and that's
what they actually were they would they
would assemble you know hey all of us
are gonna get together they would kind
of elect who's gonna run it and then
they would decide what they were gonna
do sort of by consensus that's what
these original commando units were
Winston Churchill he worked as a
reporter during this war and he was
captured I think he was captured on a
train mm-hmm he was put into a prisoner
of war camp he escaped I mean that's
kind of one of his that's one of the
things that made Winston Churchill
Winston Churchill and that's out also
where he got this name commando that
they started using in World War two I'm
pretty sure he derived the name
committed like for the British commandos
because their activities there their
methodologies we're gonna be based on
what the what the South African doers
did what the South African commando
units did and he applied that name to
the kind of the early special operation
types troops in World War two and
there's another thing that I
think about when I when I think about
the Brewers and the I think this kind of
captures certainly an attitude that is
prevalent in Special Operations Forces
and really in the military and it's a
it's a saying it's kind of wrapped up in
a saying that the that the South African
Boers had and the the the saying is and
I'm not gonna do this right because you
know it's a foreign language but the
saying is on borma complan and and what
it means is a boomer makes a plan and
it's pretty cool saying because what are
you doing something goes wrong what do
you know what's what's our what are we
gonna do when something goes wrong you
know we're gonna do a boo is gonna make
a plan we're gonna figure it out or
gonna we're gonna do something about it
we're not gonna sit back and just let
things unfold that was their attitude
that still their attitude and and of
course look South Africa has been a
place of a lot of turmoil apartheid it's
it's been you know financially just a
disaster at some points it's it's just a
tough place now I've been there I've
actually been lucky enough to have been
down there it's an awesome country it's
an epic country the the nature there's
just unbelievable shout out to the
troopers down there in South Africa Paul
slayed his his South African crew at his
company they have they have legit
jujitsu shout out to fit fight fit
militia down there and you know that was
interesting
awesome guys awesome gym guy named chef
and yes chef who's who's legit and and
his buddy rich they run this gym down
there and why we went there and trained
when I was in South Africa I had like a
it seemed like about a 14-hour death
roll with chef who's a total beast
penny Thomas also from South Africa
penny comes out to to penny Thomas but
incredible place incredible place and
you know that Jim was amazing what they
were doing in that gym and one thing
that kind of surprised me is it was
totally wide open like every different
type of person was in there rich kids
poor kids black kids white kids just
wide open there's credible atmosphere
and everybody freaking train and all
right so if you ever are in South Africa
go check that place out it's awesome but
you know ever since I went down there
and even before that I mean it's it's
just it's a war you know you know if you
know the root word of the word commando
you always think about what this was all
about and so there's you know I'm always
looking for lessons learned there's a
there's a book called the Boer War and
military reforms and it's written by a
guy named J stone and another guy named
her win Schmitt --all and it's an a very
interesting book the way it analyzes
what happened and what lessons were
learned and I'm gonna focus on the
lessons learned that they pulled from it
and I'm sure at some point there's I've
gotta but I've got quite a few good
books of you know the normal Jocko
podcast first-person account of a guy
that was on the battlefield which look
some of these battles were just insane
especially because you get to see the
well will will will just will just jump
into it so a couple things to kick this
thing off here we go going to the book
Britain was unique among European great
powers in retaining a voluntary army so
this time a lot of a lot of Europe had
conscripts still so you were just you
were just going to do your service
you're getting drafted in order to
maintain a flow of recruits equipment
had to be above above average quality
making the British Army the most
expensive in the world per soldier so
they're spending a lot of money with
government preoccupied by the budget
there was little room for innovation
much of the 19th century not a lot of
not a lot of innovation happening one of
the things that they talk about is
of all the specialized departments it
was intelligence where the dual British
deficiencies of organization and
budgetary restrictions are best
illustrated in 1899 the Germans spent an
equivalent of 270 thousand dollars for
an intelligent staff of 300 officers
Great Britain only spent 11,000 so there
they're not spending much on Intel and
where this comes to play as perhaps the
wars most glaring intelligence failure
was the lack of adequate maps of South
Africa and in particular of the Boer
Republic's the Boomers for their part
published no maps and would allow no
British subject into their countries to
draw them they gotta do what was going
on it's also interesting because for
them to make that - for them - for them
to proactively do that it meant they
knew the importance of maps and a lot of
people don't understand the importance
of terrain when it comes to combat if
you don't understand the terrain you're
in trouble here's here's a little a
little cut of what the what the officers
were like a dandified non-professional
polo-playing
officer corps recruited from a narrow
social base resulted from a system which
was itself dependent on private funding
for an officer's expenses the army was
suited to recreational life in the 1890s
an officer could absent himself from
regimental duties for as much as 250
days annually in the name of sport I
mean I'm gonna tell you right now you
get 30 days leave in the US military
these guys are getting 250 days even
when on-duty recreation was facilitated
by making an officer's time his own
after the completion of regular duties
usually about 9:30 a.m. while the ideal
of sport may have been carried to an
extreme it perhaps helped develop the
trade most often associated with British
officers their conspicuous courage that
virtue was to be indispensable for the
attainment of rank and the large numbers
of Victoria
one by senior officers attest to this
fact the officers comm courage tended to
radiate throughout the ranks so this
this idea of these just totally brave
British officers that are sort of well
that's what they count on they count on
hey we're brave that's how we're gonna
win continue on courage alone however
did not produce a good officers for
professional education and attitude were
often lacking few officers were
acquainted with foreign languages and
the writing of technical military
studies was frowned upon think about
that you're you're the officer that's
gonna lead the military it's frowned
upon to write about military subjects
crowning proof of this is the fact that
in 1900 Germany produced 50 percent of
the world's military literature France
25 percent and Great Britain 1 percent
if the raw material of tray of the
officer corps was somewhat lacking only
owing to poor training this system
served only to compound its errors so
you can see what you're dealing with
doesn't this paint the most
stereotypical picture of you know these
officer guys that are like hey I'm smart
I'm a great athlete you know you know
you know I don't need to study this
stuff on brave and you also think about
Germany look Germany has a a
militaristic nature right and any
obviously even more so before World War
Two and performed World War one even
more so think about one country's
producing 50 percent of them the world's
military literature that's insane and
the Brits are producing less than 1% a
couple other things here about what
we're dealing with long term 12 year
enlistments created a professional rank
and file in order to attract manpower
Britain had to pay in both relative and
absolute terms during prosperous times
Pat pay had to go up or the army it was
feared would be left with only the dregs
of society to deal with his perceived
problem the English army had always
maintained a high proportion of officers
and NCOs supervision was omnipresent
and individuality was systematically
stamped out of the recruit so it's a
super top-heavy organization hmm and all
their like everything's just being over
supervised and you're always being told
what to do it's always amazing the you
know in the Army or the Marine Corps
there'll be a guy that's 20 years old
and he'll be in charge of like a legit
number of guys then and whereas this is
the opposite this is where hey I've been
in the Army for nine years and I'm not
in charge of anyone because I'm getting
directed on how to do everything the
natural outgrowth of such closely
ordered system was a soldier bred to
deference and lacking in initiative you
can see where this is going how much of
this was due to process and how much was
due to raw material is open to question
in 1899 only 18 percent of the enlisted
men could be considered illiterate so
got a bunch of guys that came read
reserve components we've got to talk
about this just to let you know that
they're out the reserve components known
as militia reserves militia volunteers
or yeoman Rhee had several distinct
roles and they played the national
defense system so they're going to get
called up it's well kind of the
reservists the Army was totally directed
torn ho toured home and colonial defense
in examining battlefield effectiveness
one must go beyond questions of
organization in numbers to matters of
tactical doctrine for the British this
was most often equated with overwhelming
firepower that's what they're there
their doctrine is we're gonna overwhelm
you with firepower
every soldier received an issue of 200
rounds annually for target practice
that's a joke all training and practice
fire was carried out from kneeling and
standing positions I'm gonna promise you
you don't want to be standing on the
battlefield musketry practiced and this
is a quote consisted of firing a limited
number of rounds at stationary bullseye
targets at fixed known ranges
progressing from 100 to 1000 yards the
distance is gradually increasing instead
of decreasing as they normally do in war
once a year there was a field firing
when the battalion would spend a glow
this morning lazing away at the number
of screens set up in conspicuous
positions which in no sane enemy would
ever think of occupying that's what
they're doing they're lining up 150
rounds were to be used solely for
practicing collective fire so out of
your 200 rounds a hundred and fifty of
them are gonna be hey we're all standing
up in line too we're practicing shooting
together on the battlefield regulation
stated that infantry fire was to be open
at 450 meters as to as opposed to 600 to
1,000 meters for the Germans while the
British continued to place undue
emphasis upon volley fire the Germans
preferred individual skirmish fire large
sections of training manuals dealt with
close order battalion formations such as
the square or ash lawn which deemed
especially useful in savage warfare so
what they're talking about there is the
Zulu Wars like hey you're getting
attacked we're gonna stay in line and as
these people attack us with spears and
we're gonna gun them down and it's
important that we stay tight and put up
big volleys of fire meanwhile the
Germans are over there going hey
skirmish line you know cover and move
make a little bound forward Sir
Frederick Maurice the famed military
historian of the period lent his
prestige to a volume that taught the
advance is to be made as rapidly as
possible the main object being the
attack with the bayonet independent
firing is generally advisable only at
short range but so did you hear that
individual firing is only advisable at
short range but if an especially
favorable target presents itself it may
be ordered also at the middle of extreme
ranges whilst the attack is being
developed volleys only are to be fired
by a section or subsections till the
orders given for independent firing
that's what they're doing more
sophisticated solutions involving fire
movement cover move could not be
developed as long as heavy reliance was
placed upon the bayonet which in turn
was the most it was which in turn was
most effective in massed formations and
proved a psychological weapon par
excellence faith in the bayonet enabled
troops to advance with the intent to use
it it
was feared that if this principle was
ever called into question then the
troops would not approach the enemy
close enough to be of any use whatsoever
so they are they're using the bayonet
charge as sort of the foundational
culmination of their movement these guys
have guns you know the enemy is gonna
have guns tactical flexibility was
extremely limited
since the drill book of 1890 of 1896 did
not include any instructions for the
movement of troops in extended order
extended order means you're spread apart
they're all that closed or they're all
basically shoulder-to-shoulder oral
commands tended to be extremely formal
to the point of awkwardness for instance
one said that blank faced the blank
being filled by some objects such as a
building rather than right face
similarly one had to say advance right
incline halt rather than take cover
behind those rocks
the British tactical scheme supposed
that once units were engaged they would
function mechanically it was not
considered that morale might falter
under adversity think about that they
just think when they give the order to
go guys are gonna go morale will not
falter
during the years immediately preceding
the Boer War the army had two
opportunities to test the effectiveness
of its organization and doctrine in 1898
British Britain staged its largest
peacetime maneuvers in more than a
generation some fifty thousand men
organized in two Corps and two cavalry
brigades took part over a period of
three months the maneuvers in fact went
on only from breakfast to dinner as
officers felt the need to be free in the
evenings to attend to the London
theatres and socialize with the country
gingery terrible
this exercise was held on familiar
grounds of Aldershot which was
unfortunate sitting encouraged and
neglect of reconnaissance so you already
know so we're not gonna do any
reconnaissance we already walk around
here all the time perhaps the greatest
revolution revelation in the ineptness
of the High Command and dealing with
more troops than most of its members had
ever seen in one place their flaws noted
in the officers failure to mount
secondary attacks and a continued lack
of coordination with artillery when
forced to dismount Caverly showed
considerable firepower in the defensive
supported by machine guns on offense
however it still proved inadequate in
reconnaissance the second phase which
took place at alder shot was even less
successful in the first in infantry
advanced without the use of cover this
is a nightmare reconnaissance was poor
no digging in of trenches was permitted
allegedly for fear of damaging the Downs
the fields that they're on General Sir
Butler not having commanded troops for
12 years ended maneuvers with a
disastrous one-to-one assault after
marching his command 14 miles so you can
kind of see what we're dealing with are
you getting a picture of what we're
dealing with it's not it's not a good
picture no it's not a good picture it's
a peacetime scenario and look they were
they were in wars during these time
frames I mean I talked about what they
did they were eaten wars this was this
was England man they they were all over
the world fightin skirmishes but they
weren't getting in it in in this kind of
these tactics that they were using were
working because they're going against
people that aren't armed mmm properly so
here we go at the outbreak of
hostilities the army could muster only
27,000 so now we're getting into this
war could only muster 27,000 men in the
theater of operations whereas the
boomers field fielded 45,000 clearly a
situation different from colonial wars
in which the opponent's lacked the
ability to monitor a gradual
of British strength requesting troops
and knowing what to do with them are two
separate matters even after the outbreak
of the war no effort was made
immediately to increase the intelligence
staff or draw up plans for troop
utilization it was the army after all
that was responsible for the request
that the Colonials send only infantry
and no cavalry general Buller and this
is the guy initially kickin off the
swore the theater commander was to
complain of the last-minute plans here's
what he had to say the details were
arranged by a committee sitting at the
War Office so we already don't like that
like there's a war you're in South
Africa there's people up in England
there's no internet there's no video
teleconferencing they're coming up with
plans of how you're gonna fight this
thing they're not even there I was not
invited to attend its meetings or a
furnished with the minutes of its
deliberations I pressed for the
employment of general French with the
cavalry and for Colonel miles on the
staff I had no voice in the appointment
of the commanders or of the senior staff
officers selected this is a good old boy
network this is guys going Oh sounds
like we've got a war in South Africa
I'd like to participate in that can you
put me on put me on for him for a a
jaunt down to the colonies to
characterize British military establish
a fait establishment of 1899 much should
be made of its apathetic snobbish and
non-professional officer corps its
highly disciplined ranks and this is
you're gonna hear this a lot
let me say this also I've worked with
the Brits before there they are
outstanding they're an outstanding
military and and they obviously
transformed from what we're talking
about right now but and that this is why
though this is why and I was gonna say
they use the word disciplined and many
times when they use the word disciplined
they use it both as a as a negative and
a positive throughout this book because
they're it's an they when they talk
about the extreme discipline it's like
hey these guys weren't gonna make
decisions on their own they were just
gonna follow orders so they use that
term there and they'll also talk about
how it was a positive in some situations
as well because they weren't discipline
soldiers that would make things happen
so here we go
like
apathetic snobbish and non professional
officers core highly disciplined ranks
and conservative anti militaristic Malou
in which it functioned how else to
explain the Queen's regulations of 1899
which found space for 71 regulations
dealing with dress and only for for
musketry and one for field training
while still noting that the troops
should wear old clothes to maneuvers
since the troops would not be anxious to
buy new ones you see what we're dealing
with and here we go despite these
deficiencies the world as a whole
held the British Army in high regard in
light of its long string of victories
dating back to 1815 you know they beat
Napoleon they beat Napoleon right
they beat the world champ you know and
so now they're the champ
the British themselves believed that the
army was never in better condition
either as regards to the zeal and skill
of its officers from the highest to the
lowest the training and discipline of
the men and the organizations of all
branch of the service that's their
attitude can we say arrogance and ego
yes we can thus expiration of the Booher
ultimatum on October 11th 1899 regarding
a cessation of all British military
preparations held no major threat
despite the fact that the army would be
facing a relatively modern foe for the
first time if men and materiel obviously
not reading the whole book
there's the caveat if metamaterial
proved to be in short supply in the
early stages of the war such was not the
case with shipping Great Britain as the
premier maritime power had long been
accustomed to the movement of troops by
see the massive commitment transported a
hundred and eighty-eight thousand men
36,000 horses are four hundred nine
pieces of artillery and 1951 vehicles
over 6,000 miles without any serious
consequences
on the level of British Commerce that's
amazing
so logistically they can get it on the
British Navy the Royal Navy oh you want
us to deliver some goods we're gonna
deliver some goods supplemented by
reserves militia yeoman reval interior's
and eventually Colonials the army grew
to four times its original size by the
spring of 1940 Lee outnumbered the
combined population of Transvaal and of
free orange state
can you imagine you're going to a war
with more soldiers than they have people
and it's still gonna take you three
years to get this thing sorted out it's
crazy manpower of any sort was
increasingly welcome in the later stages
of the conflict free use of the Empire's
entire manpower could not be considered
due to certain philosophical constraints
which captain AE Oppenheim voiced we
must never this is just such a I just I
read this I was like wow this is not
this is this is very interesting here's
what this guy says this captain we must
never depart from the Cardinal imperial
principle that the Imperial Army alone
is privileged to meet any enemy at any
time under any circumstances we must
never resort to free use of native
armies of the Empire the white man
the ruling race must bear the burden in
the appeal to arms must assert its
superiority and must do it willingly and
sacrificing Lee for therein lies the
vital principle of Empire the day that
sees the white man shrinking from his
responsibilities that sees him shifting
the burden burden complacently from his
own shoulders to those of his subject
races will also see the doom of his
Imperial Dominion
now that's something that I that that
definitely was interesting to me because
you know you think of these imperialist
you think of the British Empire going in
well we got a bunch of whatever we got a
bunch of black guys down here in Africa
let's let let's make them fight and here
is this attitude of no that's not right
that's kind of crazy right it's
interesting for sure fast forward a
little bit in retrospect one cannot help
but be impressed by the war's impact
upon the Army Service Corps increased in
numbers redesigned for a lighter and
more durable in large system of animals
furthermore special bulk oriented faster
supply columns were developed for
cavalry support for the first time
limits are instituted on officers kits
this is why I highlighted this part and
the notorious cast-iron kitchen and
wagon load of champagne associated with
general Butler became a thing of the
past this is like one of some of the
things that they figured out during this
war is that it's not smart to bring a
cast-iron kitchen and wagon loads of
champagne I think it's safe to say to
put this into modern parlance is that
this is the war where [__] got real I've
been thinking about the difference
you're going to Warren you're thinking
eight let's make sure we got our our
champagne loaded up yeah so it's what
what is it I mean where does that to
come from just the sheer numbers and
history and last reman they'd been
running around you know kicking ass for
well since since they said they're 1815
you know they were British were just
kind of dominating you know and we know
what happens when you get that disease a
victory yeah champagne all day
yeah hey I guarantee you some of these
officers that they're talking about
we're thinking oh I'd like to go to
South Africa it's a little war going on
I'll go you know go and get my adventure
done yeah yeah thing and and the thing
is here's the bottom line I have this in
the notes later but imagine you're
you're used to boxing right mm-hmm and
you're gonna box someone and you roll in
there and you've you've trained a box
which means you're gonna stand up and
you're gonna throw punches and you're
not gonna kick or elbow or do a takedown
or you're definitely not gonna do
anything like I Gore you know maybe have
something in your glove and shank
someone right you're definitely not
doing that stuff yeah yeah and and by
the way so now you've been fighting
under those rules for what is it
85 years so for 85 years you've been
fighting and by the way and winning and
winning because guess what everyone
you're fighting I mean if we try to if
we try to figure out what this looked
like I bet you this looks like a
300-pound boxer that's going up against
a hundred pound boxer that's kind of
what all these wars have been like up to
this point right now hey we're gonna
roll in there and this person's gonna be
small and weak and we're gonna do the
boxing thing and they're gonna fill up
on their punches don't even hurt us yeah
they don't even hurt us and eventually
you just knock this human out and then
one day now not only do you go come up
against someone that's gonna do double
leg takedown sign nose chokes and arm
locks but they'll also chanc you yeah
you know they they don't have any rules
it's not just it's not just no rules MMA
it's no rules I'm gonna I'm gonna have a
shiv and I'm gonna cut your throat wall
you know ding ding round starts you know
I come out with the k-bar and stick it
into your spine that's what we're
talking about so why did they have this
attitude because for all these years
they were the heavyweight champ
and they hey uh I got a fight tonight
cool make sure you bring the you know
make sure you bring the shots for when
we're done yeah it's cuz it's gonna take
about three minutes and then I want you
know I want to have an after-party like
the old UFC guys I'm sure they still
good but I haven't been out for a while
but that's what it was yeah yeah like it
was so much like that that they would
bring the champagne it's like they bring
their trophy with them know exactly you
know exactly this is disease of victory
to the nth degree
yeah it's crazy man it's crazy
during the course of the Boer War the
Afrikaner armies Afrikaner armies
numbered about forty thousand men no
more of 20,000 whom were ever on the
field at one time so most people they
ever had out in the field was twenty
thousand the question then is how could
such a motley Force of farmers defy the
British Empire for so long one answer is
as a French observer phrased it was
simply the rifle the rifle of small
caliber rapid firing flat trajectory and
smokeless powder that's another big
advance you had guns that the gun the
gun powder didn't make smoke anymore
which meant you could shoot and you
could hide and you could continue to
attack and you wouldn't get to have the
battlefield filled up with smoke but
then this is a little bit it goes a
little bit further that the Brewers true
strength was not at long ranges because
they talk about how everyone thinks all
the Boomers were hunters they were
farmers and they would get really good
shots at long ranges but this kind of
just in addition to that their true
strength is not long ranges but rather
in sharp shooting at under 300 yards
lures skill in that regard was
demonstrated in the later stages of the
war when their arms were mostly captured
from the British and they still
maintained their mastery and small unit
firefights rifles alone could not assure
survival in the face of the vastly
superior British numbers and cumulative
power firepower from the beginning even
when they were overly attached to their
wagons the Brewers were able to
marched their opponents when freed from
their baggage so they eventually they
they carried wagons in the beginning and
then they finally were like hey we're
not even bringing these things when
freed of their baggage train and camp
followers the difference in rate of
movement increased rapidly brewers
mounted on ponies could on occasion
travel 60 miles a day for several days
on end and went called upon their sturdy
little horses could go for three days
without food such marches however could
only be considered them on the basis of
a ready supply of remounts an additional
factor was the Brewers Pony lighter load
weight and its distribution
the Brewers saddle weighed half that of
the British the rider carried only a
little food his rifle as ammunition in a
blanket everything else was transported
on a spare amount consequently a Boomer
Pony carried 250 pounds as compared to
the British chargers nearly 400 pounds
so lightweight lightweight means that
going back to the heavyweight versus the
100 pound guy the 100 pound guys got
some mobility and he's got some
endurance mmm they used their artillery
very well talking about that a little
concealment and protection where their
cardinal principle this is further
artillery they were for they were
frequently outnumbered in the field
several alternate alternative protection
protected positions were developed for
each gun thus permitting rapid
replacement when a piece came under fire
speed of movement was the essence of the
Boomer gunners and the British were
constantly amazed by their ability to
bring heavy ordnance rapidly into action
at unexpected locations so they would
predict positions so as soon as they
started taking fire cuz eventually when
you're shooting the enemy is gonna see
where you're at or they're gonna judge
where you're at then I started shooting
at you they would immediately move their
gun and into a predetermined position
the Brewers use of single guns rather
than battery they're talking about big
artillery guns was the focus of
considerable amount of contemporary
interest a single piece could keep an
entire army awake for a night firing at
6 miles range
the Brewers realized them the morale
effect of unreturned fire and the sense
of security provided when one is
shirred of covering fire from one's own
guns under any withdrawal they realized
the psychological warfare just dropping
bombs from six miles away from one gun
and how powerful that was the machine
gun proved more deadly and was
considered an equivalent of 25 men
thanks to the master masterly use of
terrain and smokeless powder embattled
the brewers were often able to give the
impression of greater numbers that in
fact existed Captain Slocum the American
observer noted that at the Battle of
Kolesnikova
not a single boomer was to be seen from
the beginning of the battle to the end
on occasion the Brewers would
deliberately expose themselves in order
to further confuse the enemy so in this
one of the opening battles 14,000 brits
versus 4,500 Brewers the Brits had 143
killed 755 wounded the Brewers had 8
killed the 30 wounded use of dummy guns
black powder to attract fire and command
detonated diversionary charges further
confused the Brits and the attacks had
spyin cop and Nicholson's neck the
Brewers advanced in small mutually
supporting groups rather than long lines
generally they tried to deploy their
younger men Ford their older men to the
rear and foreign volunteers still
further back so we have cover and move
going on mm-hmm
totally different mutually supporting
elements you know what the basis of
maneuvering on the but you know the
basis of fire move and cover move and
fire maneuver is mutually supporting
elements in fact the minute that you get
too far away from another element that
you can't mutually support each other
you are going to die
pushing forward by largely avoiding
concentration and attack the Brewers
forfeited the initiative and allowed
British time to deploy so this is
something that the brute that the
Brewers didn't do well is they didn't go
on the attack
the impressions they didn't go only they
didn't press the attacks they'd get an
advantage and they wouldn't take
advantage of the advantage that they had
hmm when they could no longer extend
their lines beyond the British the
British flanks conventional fighting
ended inevitably the advance of the
British and ceaseless Afrikaner retreats
took their toll on the Boer morale and
with the fall of kamati port and the war
seemed over unable to contend frontally
with the massive British armies after
the fall of bloom from Tyne the Boers
resorted increasingly to raids and
orders divert forces threatened
communications and supply gain
information alarm the countryside
disrupt mobilization concentrations
devastate enemy-held lands and release
prisoners that's the mode that they went
into that straight-up guerrilla warfare
for the Brits war soon degenerated into
a ceaseless pursuit of an elusive foe
they were all too frequently caught
unawares by Bloor commandos doubling
back in attacking favourite Buhler ploys
were setting
grass fires to slow pursuit or riding
parallel to suppose it pursuers
dismounting firing and falling by back
Booher organization and war plans are
also subjects of importance upon call
every male citizen was responsible to
present himself with ten days rations a
horse a rifle and authority 30 rounds of
ammunition so this is how the Brewers
were set up men were organized into
commandos based on electoral districts
although they were free to change units
at will this is a total decentralized
command commando would have anywhere
from three hundred to three thousand men
command was vested in Field cornet
selected one poor
Ward since command was election most new
actions were undertaken by consensus
such a system could not long survive in
warfare and we're getting this is
massive decentralized command it's
actually decentralized command to a to
an extreme that becomes ineffective and
oftentimes they end up not being able to
so one of the reasons why they couldn't
coordinate attacks work together be like
okay the enemy's on the ropes let's go
coordinate and crush them they wouldn't
quite be able to pull that off you know
they they would deal with consensus like
hey I don't agree with that idea well we
should wait a little longer than so they
don't take action so there's the
dichotomy of leadership decentralized
command is great but you can take it too
far if the three this is this is what I
was talking about earlier if the three
capabilities of any army are its
marching marksmanship and discipline
then is obvious where the Brewers fatal
flaw lay in its lack of discipline for
without discipline there can be no
coherent attack the Boomers so valued
their own lives and increased power of
the defense that they tended to forsake
the tactical offense this lack of
aggressiveness was evidenced in their
proclivity for sieges mafic Inge they
outnumbered baden-powell force 10,000
men to 700 and that they did but they
didn't attack they had 10,000 against
700 hey we're just gonna hold siege
warfare we're gonna sit here and wait
wait you out mm-hmm if I have 10,000
against 700 we're coming to get you
such unwillingness to launch attacks
consistently hurt the Booher cause
tactically and strategically even in the
field the Brewers had two Brewers been
more aggressive the British would not
have had the time to maneuver around to
their flank lack of discipline was not
only a drawback to boo attacks but also
had peculiar ramifications for the
process of surrender white flags had
never been used during the native Wars
and thus it was not understood that
everyone must stop firing when the flags
were raised by either side the British
frequently complained that while some
raised their hands others would continue
firing and that that caused problems
much to British chagrin Lord Roberts
wrote the Brewers have been the first to
introduce into war the theory that every
individual has the right to ask quarter
for himself at any moment in an action a
theory which our own soldiers seem to
have almost invariably accepted so you
have a couple people surrendered a
couple people don't that's confusing and
this is interesting
the Europeans never understood the Bohr
philosophy of inflicting damage and then
escaping into the veldt which is like
the open field they did in the bush
basically to a burger and the term
burger in this case it's basically the
white citizens down there that control
that were in control to a burger no
position was worth dying for if he could
not retreat he would surrender naturally
some might feel that horse is only
complicated the Brewers position when
kept to the rear and out of artillery
range the burger was capable of neither
escape nor pursuit the Brewers seemed
insecure with without their horses and
yet were incapable of dealing with with
cavalry when mounted so this is
something that comes up a lot you know
you had these Brits where they look at
you know the code of honor and they are
they're not gonna surrender and they're
gonna fight to the death and they're
gonna hold positions if ordered and the
Brewers are kind of like hey why would I
stay here and if I get if I'm not just
gonna die on this hill if we're gonna
lose the hill I'm gonna stay alive I
must surrender hmm so what you end up
with is a really fluid element and you
end up with a really rigid element as
commander-in-chief Buller violated one
of the cardinal rules of warfare this is
kicking off the war by dividing the an
inferior force faced with a more mobile
enemy operating on interior lines so he
one of the first things that this guy
Butler does and and interesting it's not
in this book but I read it
some of the other literature about this
this guy baller was like an old guy I
think he was 59 years old and he was
kind of not in the best of health and
the the boomers called him the red bull
cuz the name was Bullard they called him
red bull cuz his face was all I'm
imagine like you know the alcoholic kind
of sunburn yeah you know guy
stereotypical guy that's what he was and
so they kind of made fun of him they
called red bull and he had some issues
and this this whole thing kicks off in
this the in this thing that they call in
the British military the black week
because they took massive losses not
just in personnel but in on the
battlefield and even when they would
might win a battle they're losing so
many people because they're doing
they're winning battles at a massive
casualty rate so now it's it's starting
to talk about the problems the British
Army problems at the beginning of the
war and it says you just need to look at
how the various major commands were set
up in the early part of the war it says
by the Battle of graspin November 25th
1999 the British had a four to one
superiority but had come to respect
Buhler firepower in this case an attempt
was made to pin the enemy frontally with
infantry while a well spaced column of
the naval brigade was to attack the Bua
right the tactically flexible Dewar's
advanced to delay the pinning forces
while converging their fire on the blue
jackets as they bunched up to ascend the
slope despite suffering 50% casualties
the sailors broke through supported
somewhat belatedly by overwhelming
numbers of infantry again the burghers
evaded pursuit the British still
believed in their systems superiority
and overlooked then in flexibility of
their open order tactics the
disproportionate nature of losses
was still unclear so they win this
battle but they take you know 50%
casualties and one of the things that
they say is to cover up the low number
of Booher casualties stories circulated
that the Brewers and runaway carrying
their dead and wounded in reality men
rarely stop to pick up their dead when
they're being overrun so the British
kind of patted themselves on the back
and said well you know the Brewers just
took their dead with them that's why
there's no that's why there's not many
dead bodies here even though we have a
ton mm-hmm I apologize to everyone in
South Africa for my annihilation of all
these words Paul Slade I apologize at
the Battle of modern River the British
once again fell victim to poor
reconnaissance Methuen so this is
there's one of the major players here
this guy named Matthew and a British guy
expected that the board positions would
be on the far side of the river
utilizing the high ground and a village
as a defensive line instead Dale Array
elected to place his men on the forward
bank of the river in well camouflaged
positions emphasis was placed on grazing
fire over the flat belt while artillery
ranging was aided aided by strategically
placed white stones all that's mean so
they set up visual targets that they
could see and know the ranges of oh
that's nasty
from trenches the burgers could see
three miles into Matthew Owens rear as
the British troops approached the river
the Brewers opened fire pinning them to
the ground uncoordinated advances
increased the slaughter Booher Gunners
concealed 200 yards forward of some
building suspected of harboring them
wreaked havoc on the defense on the
dense British artillery formations whose
batteries had been withdrawn to 1,400
yards to escape the murderous rifle fire
and artillery fire charges weren't
impossible when men and to crawl at
1,200 yards and no one could safely ride
horseback within 2,000 yards of the
front so what happened here let me break
this out a little bit you had the art so
you had the British advancing in an open
field
the Boers
then get close enough so that they could
start killing them with rifle fire when
they get close enough and start killing
with rifle fire which is you know
probably 400 500 600 meters away they
start running away as they're out of
range
of the rifle fire what comes in
artillery pre-determined artillery
positions by whites you know white
stones that they've laid out there this
is crafty however persistent pressure on
the light left flank event finally
carried the river line and the bought
the British another victory at a
disproportionate loss so eventually they
keep they get it done right they have
enough people to get around to a flank
and they get it done the British Army of
1899 had in reality stumbled into World
War one type of battlefield the question
remained as to whether it was to be
treated as an aberration or something
new it seemed easy to blame the near
disaster on faulty maps poor
reconnaissance disregarded information
on bull reinforcements and general
misunderstanding of their intentions so
isn't that interesting do we say hey
that didn't seem to work out too well or
do we say ain't no we didn't have good
maps in our reconnaissance was a very
good and that we didn't expect this from
the Boers that's not taking extreme
ownership that's blaming everything else
not not us not us as leaders but few and
hope to covers advance by means of heavy
preliminary bombardment of the height so
now I'm fast-forward a little bit but it
they the Brewers would set up this is
just it seems so obvious right now but
instead of setting up in the perfect
position maybe on the crest of a hill
where you like have total high ground
dominance they put a little distraction
up there and they'd set up in a
different position maybe low or on the
hill or in the military crest you know
maybe have 2/3 of a third of the way
down the hill or whatever so as the as
the Brits attack and they start bombing
the top of the hill because that's where
they think they're gonna be they're not
they're under a driving rain strain
storm the
Brigade quarter columns set off for
bluer positions only be discovered a few
hundred yards from the Brewers real
positions within six minutes an
estimated 650 men lay dead or wounded on
the veldt for the rest of the day the
survivors suffered horribly as they were
pinned down by fire baked by the Sun and
ceaselessly attacked by the ants behind
whose nests many of them hid by
mid-afternoon the brigade was in a rout
defeat was clear-cut had Methuen waited
another day for the weather to clear he
could have used his balloon to explore
bluer positions too much faith had been
placed in shrapnel then they another
thing I didn't talk about this but the
boos would dig really good positions
they would dig in they would set up on
these hills and they would dig in and
they kind of described what they were
digging they would dig in really deep
foxholes that actually had to had a
little kind of roofs on him as well and
the Brits thought hey if we refer to
[__] bombs that these guys are gonna
get blown up but they was having almost
zero effect because if you're in a hole
an artillery shell hits near you you're
gonna be okay unless it goes in the hole
you're gonna be okay so too much faith
had been placed in shrapnel which had
been proven ineffective against the
trenches poor reconnaissance ineffective
artillery preparation in a complicated
night attack are we doing things
complicated
no we're keeping it simple and poor
economy of force or hardly the
ingredients of success so we have
complicated attacks that we're not
obeying the law of simple keeping things
simple law of combat and also poor
economy of force what that means is
you're not prioritizing executing you're
not focusing your efforts on one thing
hmm
and this is a common mistake that these
guys made fast-forward a little bit
while Methuen may be accused of being
unimaginative in his approach such could
not be said about General Sir William
gat acre who had actually assured in the
black week at storm storm
on December 12th he proposed to achieve
both strategic strategic and tactical
surprise by means of a long rail move
followed by a 10-mile night march up the
enemy positions before they were even
knew he was in the area he's got a
pretty dynamic plan almost from the
first his plan went awry after 17 hours
in open-top railway cars under the
midsummer Sun his command became lost in
its night March fearing discovery
Gattaca sent out no Scouts or flanking
columns as his men stumbled through the
night unclear as to his location he
decided on a flank approach to storm
Stromberg rather than on the original
direct attack but failed to communicate
to his entire command poor March
discipline of lorded the local commando
and the entire column was soon under
attack artillery men with the Sun in
their eyes managed only to shell their
own troops forcing them from a Ridgeline
they were on the point of taking at as
mishap followed confusion Gattaca
ordered a withdrawal only later to
discover he had abandoned the few salir
regiment so did I mean this is just
every horrible thing that can happen you
got a blue on blue you got the team's
lost you got them leaving an element in
the field the final defeat of black week
was suffered by general Buller at
cleanse oh just 12 miles from Ladysmith
a mere six thousand brewers repelled
21,000 British troops from behind a
thinly held River line the Buhler
position was by no means a strong one
for a front of over 15 miles they had to
hold two bridges and several fjords the
southern fjords
they have sorry Ford's the southern
Ford's were particularly vulnerable as
they were situated barely within rifle
range to their rear which formed a
natural line of defense as usual of
brewer's ignored preliminary dip
bombardment and fired only when the
British advanced at once it became
apparent
the Booher medium and heavy guns far out
range to british comparable british
pieces so this is a the way this thing
kicks off Hillyard Hilliard's a attack
went off first and was supposed to be
closely supported by Colonel Long's
Field Artillery the 1889 drill book
recommended that unsupported artillery
not moved closer than 1700 yards from
the enemy without notifying anyone long
advanced within 700 yards and unlimited
unlimbered as when you detach your
weapons from there like your big guns
you have him on wheels you detach them
that's unlimbered unlimbered in close
order although this tactic worked in
Egypt in 1881 here his gunnars were shot
to pieces by boo riflemen later Longwood
claimed he had intended to unlimber at
over 2,000 yards but it had been
deceived by the night so he's making
excuses Butler was one of the most
popular and personally brave commanders
in the army he was actually a recipient
of Victoria's Cross of the highest award
his care for men was legendary and
closely entwined with his reforms in the
Army Service Corps however his
preparations were overly meticulous and
in the midst of the South African summer
his wagons carried great coats for the
infantry got to keep these guys warm in
South Africa in the summer
despite his concern for his men Butler
had proved a poor troop commander who
attacked with little knowledge of
terrain or enemy dispositions his
command control is an adequate orders in
precise and the withholding of two
brigades in the face of a vastly
outnumbered enemy was unprofessional
this guy's making all kinds of mistakes
the defeats of the black week
collectively had a greater impact than
Dunkirk Britain at the peak of her
powers had been mauled by a nation of
farmers the insularity of decades was
shatters shattered latent Fortin
latent foreign animosity revealed it
safe itself in the international press
yet the nation rallied to meet its
moment of crisis head-on as thousands
volunteered for service Lord Roberts had
been appointed to supersede Buller
when the latter and a fit of post defeat
depression that signal general right
that he might consider surrender shaken
by his demotion bulla resolved to attack
anew before Robert's arrival by means of
turning the Boer right flank so this is
just like I mean can you imagine what
this the whole scenarios like this guys
he's saying I'm gonna surrender and then
he gonna fly off the handle goes no I'm
going to attack and I mean we're just
talking disaster mm-hmm emotional
disaster the whole world knows that you
just got beat by a bunch of farmers I
mean you're the heavyweight champ and
you just had a guy show up in a whatever
he's weighing in a hundred and twenty
five you're 300 pounds wearing
basketball shorts yeah he showed up
wearing basketball shorts barefoot and
he kicked your ass so he goes to try and
make this happen
some 1,700 men were to assault the hills
1700 forty feet high in the center of
the brewer position the rest of Butler's
20,000 men were to look on and do
nothing this is where you gotta
prioritize and execute you understand
that prioritize and execute means you're
gonna take your resources that you have
and you're gonna focus them on getting
something done instead of saying well
I'm gonna keep reserves over here and to
keep reserves or here in the Senate you
know and I'm gonna send 1,700 people to
take a thousand of 17-under foot tall
tall Hill
I got 20,000 people this is a no-brainer
you want me to take that hill but that's
my number-one priority cool watch this
the Brewers had neglected to occupy much
of its key position but the British
failed to make the most the opportunity
in accurately exploring or enhancing it
so they get the hill incorrectly cited
shadow trenches shallow trenches were
dug by 20 sappers
while over a thousand men lay idle so
they get this hilltop and now I gotta
continue normally a battalion was was
allocated seventy spades but they had
been left behind in the ascent Colonel
Maurice complained somehow our soldiers
by dint of perverse training have
imbibed the idea that there is somehow
that there is something cowardly and
sneaky SH about sitting behind cover in
the field or at any rate if they have to
get into trenches and works it is the
Royal Engineers province to provide
these defenses so these guys got up on
top of the hill and were like hey
there's a thousand soldiers on top of
the hill there's 20 people 20 engineers
to dig and they sit back and watch a
because they think it's cowardly and B
they think that's not my job this is
weird about this is happening mm-hmm
right like we're looking back at can you
imagine you're sitting there as
thousands of people you know you're you
know you could be attacked and you're
thinking I'm not picking up a shovel and
by the way we didn't even bring shovels
and by the way we only have 70 shovels
for a whole battalion yeah I mean you'd
think that in that situation that's just
kind of the leftover added to all the
straight-up prevalent attitude of not
having to really fight fight fight fight
you know yeah because you've never had
your ass kicked yeah so like you took a
shot and now you're like I'm not gonna
worry about that yeah it's gonna be okay
yeah you get taken down like after the
first round in the first round you get
taken down and then your coach you know
in in between rounds the corner man says
how you're doing great yeah no you're
not yeah and he's like and I remember
mm-hmm
so back long time ago right before
people knew about jujitsu so this guy it
was actually my friend told me this
story about when he got in a fight and
he just learned you Jitsu and I'm trying
to remember the exact situation but
basically this is the story where he got
in a fight with a guy and then the guy
you know they gotta fight over the end
he choked him out right and when he woke
back up he wanted to fight again of
course so before they fought again he
was like yeah I'm gonna die he's like
yeah you keep you give me with that
sneak attack stuff right almost like
they're not fighting or something yeah
almost like that's just doesn't count
yeah it doesn't count it's coward kind
of cowardly or whatever you know it's
like yeah they store the guy who gets
taken down right hearing you see this
will actually even now he gets taken
down
you just wrestle me once I just wrestle
wheelies looking at the raft like wrath
stand us up kind of thing like almost
complaining about certain situations in
the middle of the fight so it's kind of
like that's that situation right there
like oh I'm not digging nothing yeah we
don't do that yeah Bry you're a PI ear
in a war by the way mm-hmm so they just
don't realize that almost you know
continuing on while virtually the entire
British army stood idle the Boer army
was free to focus his attention and
artillery on the hilltop position
lacking shelter proper equipment lines
clear lines of authority or knowledge
that artillery was finally on the way up
the British abandoned the position is
untenable
this is farmers the superior the
superiority of the individual Brewer
marksman and the inadequacy of this
small British small unit tactics was
never more in evidence throughout the
day one brigade it carried the fighting
one demonstrated and three stayed in
reserve a further testament to port at
least you had three other brigades 5,000
I'm guessing in all over again might be
like 5000 people hmm that's insane
bowlers qualities as a commander or in
many ways indicative of the army he did
not know when to draw the line with his
subordinates and this is interesting
Hart was still someone of his
subordinates heart was still marching
his men and quarter columns at the
Second Battle of kolento
despite being told not to another guy
named Warren was
allowed inordinate freedom despite
compromising the entire battle at other
times Buller interfered with poor
results such as at Twin Peaks he lacked
a sense of terrain insufficient
perseverance time and time again robbed
him a victory as did his hoarding of
reserves as if his troops were
eighteenth-century professionals at the
first battle of kolento
only 4,800 men out of a force of 21,000
were engaged at any one time and its
cyan't at spy incop 3,000 men out of
24,000 staff problems bedeviled to his
battles chain of commands were unclear
and artillery was frequently misplaced
or uncoordinated
in addition strong willed and ambitious
subordinates such as warner long and
heart were difficult to control bowler
became bowler came to appreciate the
value of cover rushes and creeping
barrages and according to maurices
official history was the original
originator of curtain fire at the Second
Battle of cleanse oh he now used so
these are some things you know he
started catching on a little bit
he now used mounted troops as a maneuver
element on the flanks of infantry that's
a good idea the new battlefield involved
protracted firefights along extensive
front coordinated with precise artillery
support and an incessant creeping
forward of the infantry whereas Buller
had taken several months and three major
engagements to develop a counter to the
Boomer methods of warfare Roberts saw a
guy get sent down to take his place
Roberts Ribe Roberts arrived in South
Africa Woods own strong preconceptions
and old india hand he placed his faith
in cavalry and cavalry and mobility
rather than the fire then firepower
Roberts had arrived in Cape early in
January to find the army everywhere in
retreat rather than create this is
interesting
rather than create immediate political
problems he allowed both polar and
Methuen to stay in command although with
limited forces this is like a little
little play in the game so instead of
just coming down there firing these guys
he knew that that would be very
disruptive so he kept them there he just
gave him like really small elements to
control Roberts would always remain
careful with generals associated with
woolsley ring with the woolsley ring and
so there is a guy named generals Lee who
saw like a war hero and a general and he
had like his crew and these guys were
part of his crew and he you know the
this guy general walls and Garret
woolsley was a war hero and a general
and a powerful guy and so he had a crew
and and these guys were part of that
crew and so he was also that's another
reason why I kind of play in the long
game you know not just gonna come down
there and fire these guys cuz Woolsey's
got a lot of power the entire army was
suffused with pettiness Hamilton and
Littleton lost no opportunity to betray
Butler and clearly and clearly
constantly fought Warren and led in
little sense so you just have like
babies right roberts funneled all
reinforcements to the cape rather than
natal despite an increasing numeric
predominance he lulled the Brewers into
the belief that he was tied to the
railways so the Brits and I haven't
really talked about the Brits were using
the railways to run their supplies and
stuff like that and so he's kind of he's
kind of letting the boomers think that
we're addicted to the railways when
ready in late January Roberts massive
army struck far to the east threatening
buer supply lines as the Brewers
withdrew from their earlier blocking
assistance French's this is one of the
Brit generals French's entire cap
cavalry division the largest such
British British unit in history was
launched around their flank for the
relief of Kimberly with victory so close
fast forward a little bit they continue
to kind of do well the Brits now under
Roberts with victory so close nature now
intervened for Roberts was incapacitated
by a cold he got sick and Kitchener his
chief of staff assumed command
kitchner launched an immediate cuz
concentric assault against the Brewers
which now which most veterans realized
had little chance of success more than a
corps was thrown into the fruitless and
uncoordinated attack so this is
ridiculous so this guy Roberts is doing
pretty well Kitchener takes over cuz
Roberts is literally gets a cold when
this guy takes over man he just goes
gets he goes hard he's trying to get a
name for himself and he starts all these
attacks trying to basically surround the
the Brewers more than a corps was thrown
and the fruitless and uncoordinated
attack commanders were ignored Kitchener
wrote about the field directing
battalions and raising havoc frustration
Mountain is mounted as battle dazed men
began to trickle back from the frontline
and wander about for lack of orders to
entrench as Kitchener attempted to
launch yet another attack he stripped
troops from a key terrain feature this
guy's just a micromanager just trying to
make things happen it's horrible to read
once back in command Roberts ceased
further assaults and resorted to ten
days of bombardment and a final night
attack so isn't it you only always talk
about how leadership the most important
thing on the battlefield and I skipped
the whole chunk of where everything's
just falling apart
Kitchener suffered one thousand two
hundred casualties he almost lost one of
the major cities ridiculous so Roberts
comes back in and just stop and then he
kind of starts these more methodical
attacks and continues that the start and
stop offenses of Roberts had but one
objective the capture of the Buhler
capitals and with that the presumed end
of the war despite continued guerrilla
attacks Pretoria the second pure capital
fell on June 4th the link-up with
general Buller on July 4th signaled the
end to all conventional resistance by
mid-december Roberts had departed and
Kitchener was left in charge of mopping
up operations
so that's kind of the the overview of
how it went down at least up till that
point the most general examination of
British Army's performance in South
Africa reveals flaws on virtually every
level of command Lord Woolsey this the
guy just talked about the commander in
chief had been excluded as the field
commander on account of his age army in
royal politics along with anti India
prejudice served to eliminate various
other candidates for the post and
general Buller rose to the top of the
list despite his recent poor showing in
manoeuvres and lack of independent
command experience although an able
staff officer like most British officers
he confused personal bravery with the
ability to lead an army this is just a
common theme and I'm not hitting as much
of it as I should in the book but this
idea of the Brits that like personal
bravery was gonna be enough to win the
day it's so strange to bad-mouth that
right because courage is you know one of
the most one of the most powerful
characteristics that we can envision a
human being with right this ultimate
level of courage and sacrifice but in
many ways it was a negative quality
because they thought if they had that
they're good to go you know then this
you want to take it back to the MMA
metaphor there's like you know you you
see that one guy that's all kinds of
fired up but he's yelling and screaming
before a fight he's highly motivated and
he might even be training really hard in
his strength and conditioning yeah and
he might be ready to go the distance he
might be ready to die when he goes in
the ring and it doesn't matter when you
get in there against someone that has
better skill than you and that
outmaneuvers you all that courage and
bravery doesn't do a damn thing but gets
you killed
mm-hmm so I guess it's not that crazy to
look at that characteristic with from a
different angle if you if you're if
you're putting your whole now look if
you have a fighter that's a wimp right
that lacks any kind of courage that
lacks bravery right they're not even
gonna get in the cage or they're gonna
be scared to get hit
they're gonna run away and they're gonna
lose but you have to have both you have
to have courage you have to have skill
yeah and kind of I mean to add to that
to the you know you get a guy MMA again
a guy who's like he's you know he's a
great wrestler great grappler good
submission guy or whatever and then the
other guys may be a really good striker
and he talks a lot of trash and
interviews and stuff so he gets under
the guy's skin the guy goes in super mad
super fired up super motivated I'm gonna
I'm gonna basically beat him at his own
game I'm gonna knock him out I'm gonna
strike you know rather than
strategically go for it you know make
yourself in a better position as far as
like tactically strategically whatever
um and then he starts to stand well mini
gets knocked out there of course you can
be motivated but Brad that guys would
just way better than you Brad you got to
be smarter than that you know kind of
thing yeah it feels like that's what
they're doing - yeah now so that kind of
wraps up some overviews of what happened
on the ground and look like I said
there's there's I got some books that
are first-person perspective on the
ground boo or war and what we can go
into those I'm sure we will at some
point but where this book goes next is
how they took the lessons learned and
what they did with those lessons learned
positive and negative but as I sit here
and look at my notes it's it's it's it's
not short there's and there's a lot of
things that got learned and there's a
lot of lessons that they incorporated
and there's a lot of lessons that they
didn't or there's lessons that they made
progress towards and then backed away
from so rather than do it right now I
want to leave enough time for that so
let's call it and we'll pick up the Boer
War military reforms on episode 233 so
in the meantime echo Charles yes since
we are trying to learn oh yeah since we
are trying to make progress yes how can
we continue to make progress as
individual humans
well first off making progress isn't
always comfortable it's not always
painless but the good news about that is
we have help
so speaking of pain and growing growing
pains if you will so joints get a little
sore when you lift indeed and I gotta be
honest I been out of the supplementation
situation for a little bit this is a
little while ago few weeks ago but I got
the replenishment of supplements mm-hmm
and what I'm talking about is as bad
planning yeah yeah you sound like the
British Army on things to blame you know
I got busy caught up nonetheless anyway
what I'm saying is look when we're on
the path we go hard most of the time I'm
not saying go hard into the ground I'm
saying you go hard that you know she got
a deep progress demands hard work got to
push the envelope so push the envelope I
heard a quote from Denzel Washington he
said ease is a greater threat to
progress than a hardship is oh that's
pretty good concur cuz true very true
but through that hardship you get joint
pain say for Denzel Wasser he worked his
whole life to achieve this level of
skill and you just took his his quote
and turned it into your little personal
advertisement for joint warfare well
that's what just happened it into my
personal I apologize to you too mr.
Denzel Washington yeah well I'm never
gonna let echo wrong he'd be happy
because I'm incorporating that into how
should I say my daily my life my
approach to life how about that
don't seek ease don't seek the rest
between sets oh you got to take the rest
between sets but don't see
the rest in between unless anyway when
you basically when you join skits or
take joint warfare because it actually
works you could have said that laughs
one minute to go you know yeah like yeah
you're probably right about that you
know what I saw a video of somebody
posted somebody posted the support
section but they were just listening to
talk and listen to you and I go backward
but they were laughing to see ya cuz
most the time I'm figuring this is the
number of people listening right now
zero like when they when they hear me
say okay echo they go oh yes over Casas
all of us for two you think they're
missing an EJ if they did that they just
missed a Denzel Washington quote you
know tells me one more time ease is a
greater threat to hardship or sorry he's
a greater threat to progress thing to
comfort then a hardship is easy
okay got it yeah good we'll give some
props to Denzel Washington it was good I
like but anybody that press stopped a
little early they didn't get to hear
that oh they missed it from you
/ - Denzel Denzel alright well there you
go and like I said joint welfare if you
don't have to it or forget joint more
fair that's your whole point that is the
point that is the whole point that's why
Denzel Washington said what he said yeah
one of the message was get your warfare
and krill oil if that was buddies trying
to say yeah essentially a dick or that's
what it what it for sure don't forget
about the don't forget about the
discipline the discipline go in cans the
discipline powder form Jaco Palmer my
recommended scenario why cuz it tastes
like a an Arnold Palmer iced tea with
the perfect amount of lemonade in there
it has a little bit of sweetness to it
but it's sweetened with monk fruit yeah
that's not sugar you're all good you're
not getting any insulin spike no you're
going smooth flatline that thing easy
money yeah and you'll get a little bit
of a little bit of height little a
little bit of a
you know you have that noise that you
use for a sound effect it's like that
high-pitched like thing that's being
prepared what's the noise there's a nail
is two of them but I'm talking about is
like it's basically like a in the old
school flash yes my camera feels like
things are about to prep yeah they're
about to go off so we need to you can
edit this you can put in when I say you
get that little and you can put it right
so I'm gonna do is I'm gonna give you
the levy little spot when you get that
little boom there you go and that's the
discipline go yeah imagine if you did
all yours all your CGI into the actual
podcast and I was talking about covering
fire and there were machine guns going
off that'd be the most popular podcast
of all time tracers the tracers coming
between us yeah that could be some
there'd be horses getting killed you
know many horses got killed in the Boer
War it's crazy
you're a Z you know think so oh think
that'd be kind of the strategy in a Lin
way right killer says yeah get the
horses mmm I think you're trying to kill
the people but yeah but we're trying to
kill the enemy the enemy horses I guess
all right in there yeah their mobility
right like it's a big target you know I
don't aim and I don't know I've never
tried to kill horse so you know have
that else we're on the last Molk
so speaking of Monk I made a milkshake
last night mmm so I mix them dark
chocolate and the peanut butter
chocolate right whatever you know not
much of a deviation it's not like a
mixed strawberry with you know with it
anyway and so the thing is that haven't
had them all trick in a while in front
of the kids and they don't you know they
don't know they think I'm making like I
don't know some dessert you know and so
they're like yeah I want some some like
cool and I give them some they drink the
whole thing and this is regular malt -
can you imagine like you can just give
your kids something that makes them so
strong and healthy and they rethink that
they're that you're just a great dad
like this course literally what I
thought they're looking at me kind of
like like can we actually have the
cousin's big
and you know their two kids you think no
I wasn't taking it back I wanted to cuz
you know it was mine but at the same
time I was like yeah man have at it cuz
they were it was just so it brought so
much happiness did you see your did you
see your son starting to get a little
bit Jack yeah that's just the ways
buddies drink one milkshake boom Jack
that's a good that's actually yeah well
now we can it's guaranteed now you know
we know it's been tested yeah yeah your
son is now jacked yes sir yes how old is
he 3 3 years get some more your kid mo
get some chocolate tea you can get all
the stuff at the Vitamin Shoppe if your
vitamin shop opens up choco fuel you
know that's what it's called when it's
call apparently yes also what we're
doing is jiu-jitsu ok look varying
levels of participation jiu-jitsu right
now I understand and I think it's gonna
slowly but slowly this tournaments going
on yeah yeah so hey that's something
some people are making it happen yeah
good so anyway so we're doing jiu-jitsu
we're starting jiu-jitsu we're
continuing jiu-jitsu so when we do
jiu-jitsu McGee get or Jinky we already
know that a hundred percent because
they're the best skis straight up that's
the the number the primary situation
factually factually as you like to see
even yep and they happen to be made in
America they don't happen to be made and
is there a problem
the fact that these guys are so
comfortable that Denzel is sort of you
know a parade rest over in the corner
shaking his head boys what's up it's a
good that's a good question um because
when you put the rift key on you you're
you're in a different world of jiu-jitsu
when you put the rift key on ya fully
and and the thing is you feel it and
here's the thing I think about most of
us is like we get used to nice stuff you
just get used to it so you could not go
back it's like if you've ever flown in
an airplane first-class it economy sucks
forever I know man when you put on a
rift key every other key that you put on
for the rest of your life is economy
that's what happening it's a visceral
insult to my sense yeah do you in the
old days man I had some keys that I felt
like I was putting on something that was
made out of concrete that's what I was
feeling this is as good as not concrete
at all it's luxurious I'm gonna say it
it's luxurious straight up and they
happened to be so I actually do say
happen to be made in America but they're
not and no harm purpose it's kind of one
of the purposes behind them yeah and
also speaking of just next-level first
class sorry Denzel comfort get yourself
some Delta 68 genes which are we need
it's like another category of clothing
yes cuz you not you're not feeling like
you're wearing jeans right you're not
feeling like oh I got to put these jeans
on I'm gonna feel constricted in the hot
now you're putting on the Delta 68 you
ready just do a straight up you know
maneuver yeah you're ready to do a
gogoplata in those things yeah so you
kind of think of it and not to go too
deep into the tangent far be it for me
but you just say far be it for dance you
know okay yes but you know okay so the
difference between ease in comfort and
functionality so if you're maximizing
your functionality and because of
comfort yeah right now yes so yeah and
even saying comfort is kind of
misleading so look if I have a sword I'm
fighting in a battle with a sword and
this sword is ergonomically designed for
my hand
ergonomic yes right performance will
increase and it's a benefit
you know it's comfortable yes you're
doing better you're more it weather be
efficient more functional more
everything comfortable yes but more seem
sane so that's the Delta SP scenario
that will work good like when you go
into battle if let's say you go into
battle and you have that sword that
organ ah mclee fits your hand
that is gonna be work really good until
I cut your frickin arm off because
that's what I'm gonna do to get in the
interesting direction you know as far as
the point but you know I dig it and
you're probably right but your lesson
over there saying that you get this
ergonomically correct sword and that's
gonna be a difference
it's fom saying bring it yeah I got your
damn arm off yeah you realize you just
assumed that I was going into battle
against you well yeah hey you're right
and you do make a good point on top of
my original point for sure and I haven't
even really trained much sword but I
will start training you're down you have
a lot of what do you call bravery and I
don't have my you know it doesn't matter
ergonomically correct or not I'm taking
your arm off strategically that's the
move that's what we're doing yeah and
you can get jeans you can get boots you
can get t-shirts you can get whatever
you want from origin mein kampf
ma I and II or Jimmy calm yes
also we have our own store if you're
interested in representing while on the
path discipline equals freedom good take
the high ground or the high ground we'll
take you that was a little sleeper one
that was good we got some designs coming
yes and by the way we're not gonna talk
about it now but the last design you
submitted to me if it's almost for full
approval I had to do a couple historical
researches make sure we're a hundred
percent okay well do one little maybe
two little things to it just to clean it
up but we're we're real happy about that
one
designed by Jocko yeah yeah it was good
I'm fired up about as far as being fired
up about a design goes yeah but yes so
you go to Jocko store.com lesson I like
this whole thing about designed by
Jacque oh that's kind of weird yeah
maybe not push down yeah but factually
it's true let's move on fashion designer
yes anyway yes Jocko story calm yet we
got a lot of stuff on there hats hoodies
shirts obviously various accessories
good stuff I think it's good so anyway
yeah and by the way if you wanna if you
like that if you listen
Podcast and you want to support the
podcast this is a way to do it you don't
you know you know we're not over here
saying like first of all we're not
saying hey you need to listen to the
next six minutes of us reading about
some random thing that we don't actually
care about or know about right we're not
doing that we're not saying hey donate
money to whatever because whatever we're
not doing that we're saying hey listen
to this if you happen to feel like oh
let's throw some support we don't even
want your support we want you to have a
t-shirt you know that's what we want yes
that way we can PID you in the wild yes
that's positively ID you there's no
there's you know you're looking over a
little glance I see a little I see a
little whatever shirt we know what's up
you know what you're gonna get head nod
yeah we're all good I will be able to
know if something goes down you got my
back yes sir right oh yeah tell me this
you're looking here something's going
down
whatever call it whatever you want
there's nine people that you can go hey
come with me one of them is wearing a
jock oh podcast t-shirt who's going with
you hundred percent hundred percent I
don't care what the other people are
wearing actually they could be wearing
what I don't even know they could be
wearing a sports team what else do
people wear on the t-shirt a
rock-and-roll band
yeah like look there's some categories
that are gonna be you know what I mean
you know but if a guy's got a chocolate
podcast t-shirt on he's coming with
automatic admission hey he might even be
there might be a like let's say you see
with a guy with a jujitsu t-shirt on
mm-hmm let's say it's that kind of
situation that's going down well he's
coming to you saying he's coming to ya
yep very similar so you might as well
just prep for that moment and represent
and by the way look it might not be me
it might be some other trooper out there
yeah that's gonna that's gonna that's
gonna detach that's gonna look around
that's gonna make the right decision at
the right time yeah that's gonna
understand what you say when you say
cover me
yeah they're gonna go got it boom we're
already in action yeah we got a militia
we got a commando so true food if you
want you have a choice between someone
you know is on the path
so versus someone who you don't know I'm
not saying that now I'm saying you don't
know and if they're on the path you kind
of know them right they didn't get it
they didn't just get that t-shirt right
right they listen to the podcast they
know where we're coming from they
understand there's gonna be some some
some suffering that might unfold in the
next 13 seconds while this situations
happening we got it you know so anyways
you might wanna get yourself a darker
podcasting shirt yep calm we appreciate
it
yes sir also subscribe to the podcast on
your favorite or your preferred podcasts
listening app application whatever
anyway yeah so subscribe if you haven't
already and you know leave a review if
you're in the mood I think yeah it's
good it's good too if you want to look
throw a little communication our way we
I read the reviews yeah haven't
highlighted one well I got to read a
funny review I'm gonna go on there pull
up a good review you for a while its
copy and pasting some of them cuz they
were really good had they had something
that we like to refer to as later so
what else we got up don't forget about
some other podcasts we got a podcast we
had a podcast it was called the thread
will be re-releasing it soon I I said
we've were coming up with a new name and
we are but that's what we're doing so
that'll be out soon and episode 8 yes
everyone's been asked before I'm sorry
it's been taking a while we got the
grounded podcast where we talk about
jiu-jitsu somebody just asked for a
podcast about women's jiu-jitsu for
jockle podcasting we already had it we
had on the grounded podcast so check out
grounded podcast if you want to hear
about jiu-jitsu and life or your kid
podcasts just get your kids on the path
set them up to have an awesome life get
them on the warrior kid podcasts if you
also want to support a warrior kid you
can go to Irish Oaks ranch calm and you
can get Aiden who is making soap which
allows you your family your friends
everyone you know if you get this soap
you can all stay clean
yep speaking of which if I'm not
mistaken here and it looked deep into it
but I saw I saw hints of a new warrior
kid so yeah yeah just a cute little
hints yes so you want your children to
stay stay oh yeah also YouTube channel
we do have a new YouTube channel for the
video video version of this podcast
excerpts on there if there's anyone that
would like to see CGI special effects
during the podcast
let's get echo freaking working harder
because right now he's just cut what do
you how hard is this you show me you
show you you show me you show you this
podcast you didn't say anything so it
just basically me me me yeah you you're
not doing any work but but that's where
can we get some some horses trampling
across how cool would that be what do
they call it when they only hide
something in like a video game or a
movie they hide something that you got
to look for Easter it yes people should
go onto YouTube and they see when I
mentioned something yeah you know all of
a sudden there's a Zulu warrior over my
shoulder or what happened you know they
yeah that's that's very good I is it
that you claim to be the creative guy
and I'm over here coming up with all the
ideas I don't have you notice that no
where are you i I don't think you are
I'm covering a moving final thing how
about this we'll look into it cool if
you don't put a special effect at least
one thing that happens during the
podcast uh-huh you're disappointing
everybody that's here I'm I'm sure
that's factually correct oh I guarantee
that's factually correct you know when
we did the audiobooks for extreme
ownership and that I Connor be a
leadership extreme ownership so if you
listen the extreme ownership audiobook I
don't want to try and make it sound
crazy but there's audio effects in there
yes there's machine-gun fire there's the
call to prayer there's some explosions
and when we when we decided to do that
well first of the main reason that's
life and I we've got like words written
in there like bump up up up up up ah
right like machine-gun fire and I don't
want to start off the chapter going
you know furnaces this one chapter six
simple starts off with the word boom
right it's trying to tell you an
explosion just happened I didn't want to
have to say that right so I said you
know we decided what a bunch of these
chapters start like that here's one
enemy tracer rounds zipping overhead
right I don't want to have to make that
noise so what we did was they put
special effects in there and the the
company would that the publisher was
kind of active they were cool but they
were kind of acting like this was like
it was crazy
like it was a little bit of a crazy idea
so anyways they did it and that's a lot
of people are stoked on it but you got
to be ready for it cuz if you're driving
in your car and you hear an explosion or
machine-gun fire especially if you've
been in the game you know if like for
real you might get a little bit of like
a little bit of the adrenaline flow no
big deal all good so yeah maybe so I
think that the same way that that will
enhanced the audio books for the
dichotomy leadership yeah and an extreme
ownership if someone had the requisite
skills to actually make something cool
in here it'd be good alright well I'll
keep it in mind okay we also have
psychological warfare if you need a
little psychological hitter when you
need to go overcome a little moment of
weakness you can just check out
psychological warfare it's on all the
mp3 platforms flipside canvas if you
want a visual representation of the path
check it out flipside canvas calm Dakota
Meyer putting cool graphic
representations of things that you can
hang on your wall we got some books we
actually it seems like we have a bunch
of books there's a reason we've got the
code which just came out which is a real
good way just to step up and just go for
it that's the code we got leadership
strategy and tactics Field Manual we
got--we the warrior kid one two and
three we got Mikey and the Dragons
we got discipline equals freedom of
Field Manual we got extreme ownership
for that I gotta mean leadership check
out all those books if you want
to good information and I'll tell you
what's cool I hear this all the time you
read the book once and you're like ah
you know I grabbed it I grab you know
you took a page notes you can take a
page notes on that book if you read it
50 times in row you'll take a page in
notes every time on any of these books
that I'm talking about even the kids
books hmm yeah I believe it fully so so
check those out we got each Dashiell on
front which is leadership my leadership
consultancy where we solve problems
through leadership if you need help with
the leadership in your organization then
go to Ashland front comm for details we
also have an online platform called EF
online.com where we train coach mentor
discuss guide people through
pre-existing volumes that are on there
and through live webinars that we're
doing all the time so if you actually
have a question for me go to EF online
comm come to one of our live webinars
and ask me your question that's what's
happening so we also have the muster and
I'm I you know look this is going back
and forth we got the virus this and that
way you had to cancel Orlando I'm making
the call right now Phoenix is on we're
going to Phoenix we're going to Phoenix
Phoenix Arizona September 16th and 17th
I actually just got off the phone with
Jamie I'm like can we do this Jamie says
we can do this and I said all right rock
and roll look and if we get to that
point in September and we still have to
do some kind of social distancing
scenario whatever we got to do we got to
do it but we're gonna make it happen so
it's gonna sell out everything we do
sells out if you want to come and in
look here's the deal depending on the
social distancing mandates we may have
to limit the seating more than we
normally would which means if you want
to come buy your tickets now so you
don't get cut off because you thought
there was going to be more seats so
that's it it's September 16th and 17th
in Arizona it's December 3rd and 4th in
Texas
Dallas Texas people would said we should
have gone to Dallas day one and we
probably should have and I'll tell you
another thing we went to Austin and it
was awesome we did it kind of last
minute and when we were in Austin people
like hey come to Dallas so we're coming
to Dallas that's December 3rd and 4th
we're gonna do that one too by the way
who wants to get some and of course we
have EF overwatch if you need executive
leadership at your team if you need
senior leadership at your team and you
want somebody that's experienced that's
been tested then go to EF overwatch comm
its military leaders from Special
Operations from combat aviation that
understand the principles we talked
about here and can employ them in your
company and if you're a vet and you have
those kind of experiences go there as
well so we can connect the dots also
America's mighty warriors dot org
momily mark lee's mom and she is put
together an organization that helps
service members it helps their families
it helps gold star families all over the
world guys that are on deployment guys
that are home from deployment guys that
are active duty guys that are retired
she is just unbelievable of what she
does so go to America's mighty warriors
at dot org to either donate or get
involved if you want to get involved and
at this point if you haven't had enough
of my horrible horrible inexcusable
pronunciations of various languages or
you want to hear more of echos sort of
bewildered stream-of-consciousness
thoughts that you can find us on the
interwebs as Twitter Instagram and of
course Facebook echoes that echo Charles
and I am at Jocko willing and thanks to
our military men and women out there
around the world in uniform who stand
and face the darkness and
Oh everyday then thanks to our police
law enforcement firefighters paramedics
EMTs dispatchers correctional officers
Border Patrol Secret Service who stand
and face darkest and evil here at home
and to everyone else out there do not
fail to learn do not fail to learn adapt
to new environments change the way you
operate don't get stuck in the past get
better and get better and improve and
the way you do that is by going out
there and getting after it and until
next time this is echo and Jocko out